Frank Newport is editor in chief of the
Gallup poll in polling matters he
explains how polling works and its
impact on elections this talk is an hour
good evening everybody and welcome to
Barnes & Noble Princeton
I'm Nancy Nicholson I'm your community
relations manager and I'm very happy to
welcome you all here to our book signing
tonight as you all know I'm sure we are
now entering most one of the most
important if not the most important
election in American history and many of
us are taking a renewed interest in the
news in commentaries on national and
local politics and throughout American
history opinion polls have been quoted
in the media since 1936 the Gallup
Organization in Princeton has been the
leader in this field however many
leaders in the world throughout history
have ignored the advice of polls as a
matter of fact if I was going to hire
the Gallup poll tonight to take a poll
of you to see how many of you enjoyed
this event or what you thought there's a
good possibility that I might get a
couple of letters or phone calls asking
me if I was a girly man so how much does
individual opinion matter our opinion
polls statistically accurate the
legislators believe that the average
American is informed enough to make a
good decision about very complex matters
and what about the internet will
Internet technology provide a more
accurate way soon to measure public
opinion and at election time how does
the advance publicity surrounding polls
affect the populace well I'm very happy
to welcome dr. Frank new part he's a
commentator on CNN and editor-in-chief
of the Gallup poll he can answer all of
your questions and more and he cares
what you think
ladies and gentlemen dr. Frank Newport
thank you very much Nancy they told me
to make sure that I left time for
questions and answers today but of
course we don't believe in questions
where we are the Gallup polls loudest
babble for the whole time like many
politicians do and don't won't have time
for the people no actually we'll make
sure that we leave plenty of time for
questions I was the other day at the
Democratic convention to me the
Republican convention in New York City
went in to do some interviews and
observed the festivities there and was
on Al Franken's Air America radio show
which you may be familiar with if you're
familiar with Rush Limbaugh on this side
of my body clearly you're familiar with
what side of the spectrum Al Franken
would be on the other end of the
spectrum but he thought he would catch
me to the first thing he asked me when I
sat down live for his listeners was I'm
asking you this question would you
please answer it if the election were
held today who would you vote for George
Bush or John Kerry tell us exactly how
you feel now he said you asked the
public these questions so you have to
answer them for us right put me on the
spot at that moment because one thing
we've learned over the years is at
Gallup is to be extraordinarily neutral
in our approach to what we do it's a
core belief an element of what we do as
a company and I of course try to be
neutral as well so it was it was
difficult I cleverly avoided that by
saying well one of the things that we
promise it Gallup when we call people up
and do surveys is that their response
will be completely anonymous which is
true if you're calling the phone and do
a Gallup poll your name your address
anything we know about you would never
be associated with your response and in
kind of individual basis so it allowed
me to say to Al Franken I would be happy
to answer that question however I'm
hardly anonymous here i flattered him
and said in front of your tens of
millions of listeners here on the air
America radio show so I managed to
weasel out of that response from Al
Franken at that time but we do believe
in questions and I ask questions so I
think it's turnabout is fair play
particularly in a political season like
this our email system is flooded with
people who write in most of the time
they are irate people on one side of the
spectrum of the other we'll go into this
in a few moments but at this particular
moment in time we are hearing from a lot
of Democrats who are responding saying
for a variety of the host of reasons
these are the reasons why any poll that
shows that George Bush is ahead at this
point must be flawed and they're quite
specific and telling us all the reasons
why our polling must be flawed but let
me assure you the moment that we show
the Democratic candidate moving briskly
ahead we hear exactly the same thing
from the Republican side of the spectrum
I noticed already John Kerry for
president right here in front of us the
people in this area certainly unabashed
not unabashed in the Greater Princeton
New Jersey area about expressing their
political preferences so I'm sure we
will get some questions which we will
attempt to answer we take our
responsibilities at Gallup quite
seriously we believe providing public
opinion back to the public is a very
very core and important part of
democracy and we try to be as open about
it as possible and tell people exactly
what we're doing and how we're doing it
and why we're doing it and if there are
questions and occasionally I must admit
occasionally we do make mistakes and
things go wrong and when that's the case
we're the first to try to correct it and
explain it so for that reason I want to
make sure that I leave some time tonight
for us to be able to talk about a wreath
to attempt to answer my questions of
course if there are questions which I
can't answer like any good politician
I'll say that's an excellent question
and I'm glad you asked it and if you
leave your name and address my staff
will get right back to you right but
tomorrow which is the time-honored
Pollak political way of responding to
questions I will tell you who's going to
win the presidential election tonight
all right but you got to wait to the end
of my little remarks here before I tell
you so we'll keep you seduced into
staying at least with this and not
drifting over here to the alternative
medicine section in the middle of this
poll and looking for something more
interesting than talking about polling I
want to just to introduce a couple of
well I see mrs. gala but I don't
ecologist dis very briefly I wanted to
acknowledge a few people like Kim wave
your hand this is a spousal unit Kim
Newport my wife whom I acknowledge in
the book and dedicate the book to
because she was really the force behind
my finishing the book there are many
authors in the world who have great book
ideas many of you in this audience
perhaps had great ideas for books some
of you have actually started books right
but it is the rare group of people who
actually finish a book once they started
and I was in that first category of
starting the book great ideas a lot I
wanted to
right but it really took the prodding
and the encouragement of Kim among
others to push me to the point where I
got the book finish so I wanted to
acknowledge Kim for that behind her is
just very good laws for Kim behind her
judith Kinnaman wave your hand Judith is
my assistant at the at the Gallup
Organization and Judith not only helped
me write the book she figured out how to
decipher handwriting which is a real key
for me I worked at a radio station when
I was going to Vale University I'll tell
you more about that in a moment with
people in about 10 years later I bumped
into somebody that had known me at the
radio station
Oh Frank Newport you're the guy with the
small handwriting that's all he
remembered about me was that I wrote so
tiny that he couldn't remember well
Judith figured out how to do it and
she's been a great help on this book and
helping arrange the event tonight and
what have you and finally I wanted to
acknowledge but I don't see Malik Gallup
where is he
he's in the vicinity I've heard he has
been spotted Barbara is that accurate
but he's not here this is mrs. barbara
Gallup wave Barbara thank you very much
chef I wanted to acknowledge and I'm
going to talk a little more about it but
of course Princeton is the home of the
Gallup poll founded by dr. George Gallup
back in 1935 were almost up to an
anniversary year here he had a wonderful
family and two of his sons George Jr
who's actually I believe George the
third although everybody calls him jr.
and Alec had been very much involved in
a Gallup poll for all those years and to
this very day or at our office here in
Princeton when we come to work every
morning I wanted to acknowledge them I
don't see George but I was told and
Barbara assures me that alec is in the
vicinity it's when he does come up I
want you all to wave to him and and say
hello to Alec Alec has been a great
encouragement because he knows so much
about polling you know he was at
literally at his father's knees and feet
when his father was polling in the in
the 40s and the 50s and if there is a
question do we remember did we ever ask
the public whether or not they think it
is appropriate for topless bathing to go
on in our nation's beaches Alec is the
first to say yes we did ask that
question back in the in the 40s but it
was asked about men not women at the
time which is actually a true story
those are the kind of historical
references that Alec
provides for us that we don't have in
any book so it's been of great
oral history the tradition to the Gallup
poll have really been carried on by Alec
over the years and it's been a great
pleasure for me to work both with Alec
and with his brother George Jr over
these many years speaking of the gallops
what I wanted to tell you a little here
tonight is the trajectory of two men
which is really kind of what came about
when I when I wrote the book
polling matters one of the men who's
very much in this book is dr. George
Gallup himself a man that I never met
the other is myself
Frank Newport which I have met and I
will talk a little about him in just a
few moments but dr. Gallup died in 1984
he lives most of his adult life here in
Princeton he actually died in
Switzerland right Barbara he was on he
had a home in switch and li-like
Switzerland that's a great story because
as I'll relate to you in a moment dr.
Gallup I had a great reverence for
public opinion in the wisdom as do I
there really boils out of the collective
opinions of groups of people and one
reason he liked Switzerland and he's
into that day into this day they have a
great reverence for the people of the
villages and the other jurisdictions
coming together and hammering out
solutions to problems together
collectively and I think that's one of
the reasons I'm told that he always
enjoyed going back to Switzerland and he
was at his vacation home there when he
passed away
back in 1984 I never met him I didn't
show up here at Gallup until 1990 so
like ships in the night I knew of him
and about him but I never met him
but the more over the years that I've
talked to his sons and those who knew
him and more importantly when I've read
the books in the writings of dr. George
Gallup I've really come to respect and
admire dr. Gallup and I've learned a
great deal about from him about polling
and what polling can represented in a
democracy and how important polling can
be to all of us not only here but around
the world so let me tell you just he was
an Iowan he wrote his doctoral
dissertation at the University of Iowa
on related to polling but it was really
related to using research in some ways
to help sell newspapers he was very
interested in advertising research so I
am told he's one of the first ones that
figured out if you want to know whether
newspapers should leave certain comics
in the paper or take them out ask the
people and he figured out ways of doing
samples and having mock newspapers and
all of that and he provided research to
newspapers and what-have-you
became well-known did this did that
taught here taught there but he moved to
Princeton actually not to have any
connection with Princeton University
which he never did we are told that he
and Albert Einstein used to have coffee
together on Nassau Street and dr. gallop
would ask Albert for Al I'm sure he
called him Al baby maybe that's what he
called a line Stein for little tips or
pointers on how to do you know random
sampling and statistical analysis but I
think all of that separa fool from what
I hear although they did know each other
but he moved here not related to
Princeton University but he moved
because he took a job as an advertising
research manager at an ad agency in New
York City he the depression and the
story goes that he needed to live
somewhere Princeton looked blige in he
had friends and he bought a farm out
there north of Princeton to which to
this day the Gallup family lives on and
that's why he settled in Princeton but
it was commuting into New York along
came the election in 1936 and dr. George
Gallup said I will do some what we do
today and some polling to figure out
who's going to win in the election now
it's a fascinating story because at that
time there was a magazine which in its
day was well known called the literary
digest magazine anybody here familiar
with it
well the I'll tell you in a moment why
you might not be totally familiar with
it but it had done its own straw polls
of presidential elections actually for
historical footnote the various
individuals have been doing polls of one
sort of the other relating to
presidential elections going back to the
1820 so historians told us and still do
tell us so the idea of people wanting to
know before an election what the public
is thinking and who's likely to win the
election is certainly not new at all to
us it's something that so many people
have been interested in for many many
years and people had attempted to do one
way or the other to try to figure out
which way the winds were blowing I just
read a biography by edmund morris of
theodore roosevelt and he was taking
polls and trying to figure out what was
happening at his time at the turn of the
century but the literary digest has had
some success by sending out literally
millions of straw poll ballots in its
time he would get mailing lists from
wherever it could bring them together
and it would send out I'm told 1014
million of these straw ballots that they
would send out all over the country and
people would mail them back in saying
who they're going to vote for and they
would tally them and they would
the results as you went through the fall
and say here's what we're finding here's
who's going to win the election the bad
news for the literary digest is the good
news they were quite successful in the
elections of the late 20s and in 1932
they had been very accurate in
predicting what had happened Theodore
Roosevelt of course won in 1932 so when
the time came for the 19th hmm FDR I'm
sorry
sharp sharp audience I've got to be
careful here
one slight misstep verbally and I'm
immediately pounced on by the high IQs
in the audience well I need to be quite
careful I'm glad we're not getting a
lecture tonight on statistics because I
think some of you would really take me
to task
at any rate Franklin Delano Roosevelt
running for reelection in 36 the
literary digest did the same thing got
its ballots in and had over 2 million of
those straw ballots were in place they
were convinced the ballot said that
Roosevelt was going to go flaming to
defeat that his opponent at that time
who was huh Alf Landen very good
it was his opponent at the time was
going to sail on to victory so goes the
literary digester literally over 2
million ballots had come in and told him
that that was going to be the case
George Gallup courageously using the
research techniques and the sampling
techniques although in crude form but to
be honest with you what dr. George
Gallup was doing and other pollsters at
his time were were not employing the
same random probability sampling message
that we use now but in principle they
were moving in the direction of trying
to allow every respondent in America
every voter in America to have a chance
of falling into our sample and some kind
of proportionate sense so Gallup went
out dr. Gallup and did sampling small
samples actually large by our days I
think he may have had by the time he was
through 10 or 15,000 responses in his
sample but he had been much more
conscientious in attempting to apply
these kinds of principles this is 1936
he went out he said no no no my day to
show that Franklin Roosevelt is going to
be reelected but George Gallup had the
courage of the convictions that many
pollsters today still don't have and
that is to go out publicly before the
election and announced what his polling
was saying he went in the newspapers The
Washington Post among others they
courageously put dr. gallops estimates
right in the newspaper quite publicly
people were astounded here's the
literary digest with two
million boats and it's straw ballot
they've been quite accurate in previous
elections and here comes this guy named
dr. gallop and he has just a few
relative few thousands and he's saying
Roosevelt's gonna win hahaha what a fool
he is well it's a great story for
pollsters or I wouldn't be telling it
right if Landon had won the election I
wouldn't be here perhaps dr. George
Gallup probably wouldn't have become
famous but of course Roosevelt won
reelection Gallup became famous the
literary digest the great day new mob
the story goes went out of business a
few short years later and that's why
probably nobody in this room has heard
of the literary digest at this point
because they had now I am told by those
who are skeptical historians that there
may be another business reasons why the
literary diet is one that a mag is
nostalgia gallop was launched became a
household known became world famous for
this idea that small samples of people
can actually represent large numbers of
people if you do the sampling correctly
it's the same moral of the story that we
give today when somebody calls in and
says somebody just did a poll on the
Internet and they have 82,000 people who
voted or gave their answer on the
Internet and it shows X while our poll
showed why we come back to that same
principle it's not the number of
respondents in the sample that matters
it's how those respondents were selected
the same principle that dr. Gallup came
up with all those many years ago is
really the core of what we do today dr.
Gallup went on in his career established
a poll a IPO American Institute of
public opinion research here in
Princeton while still commuting into New
York and working for the ad agency there
became well-known continued to poll and
we had a little incident in 1948 but we
really don't have time to get into that
much here one of the reasons that we
have better polling techniques today
than we used to is in 1948 dr. Gallup
among and other pollsters at the time
were convinced that Harry Truman was
going to go down to defeat
so turnabout is fair play I guess for a
variety of reasons apparently Harry
Truman charged from the end and brought
in a lot of farm boat and of course he
won the election famously remember Harry
Truman holding the newspaper at the
Chicago paper saying duly elected right
Dewey wins which was of course based on
everybody's firm conviction based on the
polling that he would win and that was a
lot of
think Alec would tell us if he were here
was probably his father's a toughest
moment his whole life you know he was
famous he believed firmly in polling and
here he came in to visit debacle that
polling failed it must not be any good
he devoted much energy many months many
years to trying to research and find out
what had happened a variety of issues
there among which were the methods
themselves quite a sampling methods he
were using really weren't as appropriate
is the kind of random sampling that we
do today so we that's been revised and
second they stopped polling too early
the last poll Gallup did was a week or
two before the election and now we've
learned if nothing else over the years
that the electorate can really move
right up to Election Day itself and
that's why we now poll and we'll be
polling this fall our last poll actually
last year was Monday night but at least
in terms of the published polls will be
polling right up through Sunday night
before the election and then in USA
Today and on CNN on Monday and on our
Gallup cop website we will have our
final estimate of what's happening even
there we're trepidatious because we've
left 24 hours for people to change their
mind so we try to get as close as we can
to what's happening the key point about
dr. Gallup though that really resonates
with me and one of the reasons that I
wrote this book
there's Alec Alec wave to us yeah Alec
Gallup I've been talking about him
thanks to Alec glad to have him here I
was saying before Ali got here great
mentor and friend of mine and is
knowledgeable by polling as anybody in
the world I would say at this point the
present company included identity ray
doctor Gallup was extraordinarily I
wouldn't use the word hurt but by
nineteen he started remember in 1936 and
by the early 1940s was writing in his
books the books that I've been going
through in my office of the last three
years and reading every word of he says
with chagrin with concern and with some
dismay he says public opinion polling
itself has become the subject of public
opinion and he had discovered fairly
quickly within years of putting his
polls out before the 1948 miscall of the
Truman Dooley election that there was a
lot of resistance and criticism of
public opinion polling it came out dr.
Gallup from all angles at that point he
started writing books the one that I
liked the most was called the pulse of
democracy which he wrote with Saul Rea
back in 1940 1941 a great book but it
was written if you read it today in
large part to defend polling and tell
people why polling
was important in fact the pulse of
democracy as he says in his book and it
didn't stop there
you know alec has given me a large
compilation of dr. Gallup speeches and
if you look through them you find many
of them were defenses of polling trying
to react to criticisms he would get off
of that he believed firmly that the
election system should be reformed
that the electoral college system was
was dumb we needed popular vote that we
needed campaign finance reform that we
needed reform in the way primaries were
run dr. Gallup was a fervent believer in
a lot of those kind of reforms but
unfortunately he kept being brought back
to this whole idea that something's
wrong with polling polling is bad for
democracy and polling doesn't work and
he continued to write books until you
know up and almost at the time he died
where he was at one point of the other
addressing those issues the
sophisticated poll Watchers guide I
thought was a great title and I almost
took it from my own book and said the
sophisticated poll Watchers guide number
two because I thought that was a quite
useful title this book but that's
another one they wrote to try to respond
to polling well along I came as a young
man quite not interested in polling per
se but in high school as I tell the
story in the book I got quite interested
as I am to this very moment in human
behavior there are a lot of
psychoanalytic reasons behind that that
would be too many to go into at this
point I'm sure but by studying human
behavior I think one thing you can do is
avoid having to make commitment on your
own right you can say I'm looking at how
other people isn't it interesting that
people are reacting this way without
having to comment oneself but but high
school was a great time for me in the
sense career-wise not necessarily
personally that was popular alright I
won't get into all it but not greatly
popular we had a huge high school 4,000
people Fort Worth Texas where I grew up
but what I got fascinated by at that
time was this extraordinary power of
social norms and social stratification
they were operating in my high school to
this very day have a daughter senior in
high school same exact thing is going on
now that was going on back then there
are these extraordinarily powerful
social social differentiation and
normative structures that operate in a
high school we're almost every kid in
that high school knows exactly where he
or he or she is in terms of some kind of
unknown or unspecified or on formal
hierarchy you know we have the jocks in
the Nerds and the Goths
today right and the geeks and the prep
using all of these individuals who had
different labels when I was there but
everybody knew where everybody else goes
how everybody was classified of these
groups and beyond that there was an
extraordinary sense of social hierarchy
best word for that is popularity but
almost everybody in high school knows
where somebody else is on this pecking
order of popularity in fact my son when
he was in high school did an experiment
where he went around and asked people
unbeknownst everybody else to rate and
put people in hierarchies and sure
enough when he looked at the data he
found that it was absolutely true almost
anybody in the high school at random you
could take to a blackboard and give them
a list of say 20 students in the high
school and they've been placed in
exactly where they would be on the
hierarchy and the next person would come
into the room totally blind and they
would put people the same hierarchy
what's fascinating is none of that's
written down right it's not a
designation it has nothing to do with an
official office nothing's ever given you
don't wear a tag on you this is highly
popular semi popular average popularity
not popular at all or the bottom of the
popularity hierarchy but everyone of us
who has kids or remembers our own high
school knows exactly how that works when
a kid walks into the high school today
they know exactly where they stand in
this high I says if they had a sign on
you know and a kid who's at the top very
popular is is it for many people at the
pinnacle of their lives right you can
graduate from high school at the very
popular at any rate that got me quite
interested in the power of social
dynamics and social behavior and that's
what I kind of carried on went on had
some detours is life went on got a PhD
in sociology because sociology after all
is the scientific study of human social
behavior so that's obviously the
direction I would go in one of the core
methodologies of sociology is Survey
Research so backing right in there I
became quite interested in the power of
surveys to allow us to understand how
social behavior and social structures
operate in today's world today and
that's where I got interested in social
research I did one thing I did another I
did marketing research and social
research through a variety of intricate
right alec combinations of companies the
company in which I was a partner in
Houston was acquired by a company that
in turn acquired the Gallup Organization
here in Princeton how's that
dr. Gallup had died in 1984 a few years
later the family the Gallup family made
the decision to merge with another
company to sell the company and it was a
in Lincoln Nebraska selection research
incorporated headed by a fantastic
gentleman whom I had as much respect for
almost a doctor galloping dr. Don
Clifton who unfortunately passed away
within the last year or two professor
university Nebraska he had founded his
own company in Lincoln Nebraska but it
was that company that merged with the
Gallup Organization and in turn since I
was a part of the company in Lincoln
Lowe and the whole IND DUP here in
Princeton as editor-in-chief of the
Gallup poll the core reason that I'm
bringing this up in relationship to this
book is I'm struck again and again by
how exactly I am in the same situation
that dr. Gallup confronted I have a love
for polling I have a great admiration
and respect for the collective wisdom of
the people in a complex society there is
no other way to measure this integrated
collectivity of insights than to use
Poland when you have 290 million people
in the society and yet at the same time
I am bombarded to this day and perhaps
will be in the Q&A session that we're
going to face in just a moment by some
of you with the same kind of if not
hostile question at least questioning
questions from people who don't
understand and don't appreciate the role
of polling in society same questions
nothing's new in the world every
question we got on an email I can almost
say yes now here's how dr. Gallup
answered that question some 50 years ago
not specific to certain candidates but
the types of questions he were getting
remarkably similar to what we get today
and as a result of that I said it's time
probably to try to do the same thing
that dr. Gallup did lo those many years
ago and put in a book really answers for
in justifications for the reasons why
what I just said is true why we need
polling and why polling is powerful in
society today and should be used more
rather than less by those we elect to
represent us and also to answer the key
objections they're questions that we
usually get about polling and as a
result of all of that putting that
together building off of what dr. Gallup
and Alec and the others have done over
the years and scientists have done the
polling industry is not a bunch of
wackos sitting around dreaming up data
the polling industry is actually driven
by the same type of I would say
scientific minds and knowledge and
approach to data that you would have in
physics or that you would have in
chemistry or you would have an
engineering that builds bridges you
should come to our American Association
public opinion research meetings every
year just had in Phoenix this year and
paper after paper scholarly paper where
PhDs and scientists have looked at
issues relating to polling and have
approached him in exactly the same way
that the convention of cardiologists
would approach the efficacy of using the
angioplasty as opposed to coronary
artery bypass surgery when someone has
has heart problems there really is a
scientific approach to polling and I
think it's important to try to get that
across so if nothing else for those of
us here on and on c-span watching and
elsewhere the book is an attempt to
really say
don't despair of polling don't look
critically at what polling does but
instead really realize how important it
can be for our democracy and to do that
you really need to understand how
polling is done they're really three
things that I address in the book we
won't spend time to go through them here
the first objection to polling is
elitist in the extreme and that is that
the people are stupid I can't tell you
how often I hear that from other people
who say how can you possibly trust
polling because people are so idiotic
right as if by the way to say that those
people we elect us and send off to
Washington and to Trenton and elsewhere
are brilliant right as I said I think
this article is interviewed there's
nothing that magically transforms some
lawyer into a genius the second that he
or she is elected to go off and
represent us right there still the same
flawed kind of a troubled did I say that
politicians are troubled I think maybe
we can agree the same kind of troubled
individuals that they were before we
elected and then the people individually
have various levels of knowledge about
various subjects as I say in the book
many of us most didn't do well on
Jeopardy by the way what's his name
Jennings lost oops I shouldn't say that
I did you see it on the Internet he's
the jeopardy contestant who's now won
over a million dollars they pre-tape it
somebody has leaked that like 30
episodes for now he's finally gonna lose
but don't you didn't hear it for me all
right I'm simply passing on internet
gossip that I shouldn't be passing on
all those on the news all day all right
so I'm doing nothing all right
poor guy at any rate he's a great guy
from Utah right but most people in this
room and most Americans certainly
couldn't do well on Jeopardy and you
know the level of factual knowledge is
usually low for a random sample of
America you give them a map up here and
say put pin the tail on the donkey for
where Uganda is or
or even a rock use or wear Portugal is
and most people would stick it in you
know China or somewhere independent of
that we don't have a lot of factual
knowledge but scientifically it has
really been shown again and again that
collectively the wisdom of the people
really comes together and presents a
nice a coalition of wisdom that's
greater than most people would be able
to ride independently you know if you
haven't in another book that was written
you know the collective wisdom the
wisdom of the collective that was
written recently they had you know he
uses a jar full of pennies and you try
to estimate how many pennies are in the
jar we can bring in experts but the best
way to get how many pennies are in the
jar bringing a thousand people and have
every one of them estimate look at the
arithmetic mean of that and that
estimate will be closer to how many
pennies are in the jar than any one or
two experts could possibly come with by
themselves I always love to talk about
Who Wants to Be a Millionaire right what
was the lifeline that always worked the
best on Who Wants to Be a Millionaire
was it the genius on the line at the
other end of the AT&T telephone line no
generally speaking it was the audience
who polled who were polled and came up
somehow collectively what they isolated
is the right answer to the question for
Regis tended to be the correct answer
there this is for variety of ways it's
been demonstrated scientifically we can
show it in studies that bringing people
together about issues particularly
issues that are close to home race
relations and how to solve healthcare
problem and the education issues overall
variety of issues particularly that we
live day in day out the collective lives
of the people is going to end up with a
better guidance for society than any
genius or PhD from Princeton how I'm in
that PhD from Harvard or anything like
that could possibly come up with on
their own
the best and the brightest of course was
the term that David Halberstam used for
the geniuses who all were certifiably
extremely smart individuals that got us
and helped to get us with Lyndon Johnson
into Vietnam Johnson himself was a very
very smart man you know Dean Rusk and
Robert McNamara Harvard MBA former
president CEO of Ford Motor Company you
go down the list of all these
extraordinarily smart individuals and
then you put them together will come to
questions in a moment and then you put
them all together and what you come up
with of course public policy and that
issue that I don't think historians
would agree was probably the most
auspicious time in our American
so there's great wisdom in the
collective views of the people be they
smarter be they not the second whole
category objection to polling of course
is people don't understand how it's done
interestingly polling tells us that
Americans like the idea of their
representatives paying more attention to
the wisdom of the people rather than
less you give them a quote we gave him a
question at the time of the first person
before we gave them a question at the
time of the printing and Clinton
impeachment he said as these Congress
people and Senators are off pondering
whether to vote for against impeachment
should they pay attention to their own
wisdom do they go off to the mountaintop
and ponder the philosophic you know
constitutional niceties of whether they
should vote yes or no or should they pay
attention to what the people want
overwhelmingly the the research that pay
attention to the people the data
collected on polls could continue to
show that the people feel they would
rather be represented rather than having
people trying to be smart that they send
off to represent them and that's what
we're saying here that again and again
in a representative democracy although
I'm not in the book advocating direct
democracy where we do away with
representatives altogether but a system
where we have representatives we send
off to do our bidding is out of whack
we've got too many people out there
doing what they think is best listening
to lobbyists and special interests in
their own party bosses and not paying
enough attention to where the real
source of the wisdom would come in that
is the people themselves and that's what
we're writing the book about to try to
give a corrective force to that where we
recognize that if we can get more
attention paid to what all of us
collectively think is the best way to go
in situations where usually a lot better
off in the long run particularly in
terms of broad pimp's principles than we
are if we let the people we elect to
represent a disco often and think they
know what's best all on their own but
the point was though even if you buy
into that argument which I hope you
would after reading the book is the
question of I don't believe polling
works you know how can a thousand people
represent 290 million is often the
question we've got actually there's a
very uh non that which is probably the
single number one question we get is
I've never been called we got that today
we just published of course a Gallup
poll yesterday telling how the voters of
Ohio a key battleground state this year
are looking at Bush versus Kerry I got
an email today from
nice lady in Ohio who said I don't
believe your poll because I'm a you know
37 year old woman living in Ohio and you
didn't call me so how could you possibly
be telling us how old I am steel unless
you've interviewed every single Ohio
right well as dr. Gallup used to say
when you go to the doctor you know you
want your clerestory check which by the
way is Bill Clinton's episode would show
us we all should have done very very
frequently if you want more about that
Barnes and Noble has whole racks of
health books that you should buy before
you leave how's that I wanted to make
sure I got that in as he used to say you
go to the doctor he or she doesn't drain
all the blood out of the body detector
caress trawl he's fine with the sample
right you take a small sample of the
blood and generally that can be
generalized he loved the housewife
example remember when the soup is on the
stove is it too salty he used to say the
housewife need not consumed the entire
vat of soup she stirs it up and takes a
sip and generally she's willing to say
that sample probably is fairly
representative of the salinity of the
saltiness of the entire soup there's no
need to consume it all as long as she
remembers to stir it which is very good
I appreciate that because in reality
that leads right into what we're saying
is I gave with my internet literary
digest example as long as the polling is
done right a brilliant lead in it I
appreciate that as long as the polling
is done correctly and every American
that we are generalizing to has an equal
or at least an own probability of
falling into our sample we can say with
statistical certainty that the sample
that we have is going to be
representative within certain margin of
error limitations of what we would have
found had it be possible had it been
capable of interviewing every person in
the population and it works Gallup
doctor gala blogged elections frankly we
as pollsters hate elections because it's
the one time when we're thrown out the
you know world we're held up to dry
right we're saying candidate X is ahead
on the eve of the election but on the
next day they're going to vote we're
going to know whether we're right or
wrong but on the other hand look at it
as a plus and a minus dr. Gallup
realized a long time ago that it was the
one time if we did our job right that we
could demonstrate to the American public
that consumers of our polls that it
actually worked that small samples could
in fact represent millions and although
there are
missteps occasionally if you look at the
broad view of polls that do major
elections presidential statewide
gubernatorial and senatorial elections
generally speaking there is a remarkable
level of accuracy people say well what
happened in 2000 with Gore look at the
popular vote polls that were done
gallops and others almost every single
one of them on the eve of the poll
including IRA said this race is too
close to call our last poll before the
2000 election on the popular vote said
the two candidates are within a 46 to 48
percent of the popular vote range at
this point based on our sample the dust
settled the next anillo the dust settled
months later I should say in that
election but when the dust did settle
guess what the the popular vote rounded
to 48 48 Gore had five and a thousand
more popular votes but it's still
rounded to 48 48 so within a margin of
error remarkably we had come within just
a couple of points of being precisely
accurate of where that election was
going to be and if you look back at the
news coverage of polling before 2000
almost all of them said exactly the same
thing this race is simply too close to
call the remarkable accuracy in the
record of folks and that's what I spend
on the second part of the book really
trying to explain how polling works and
how if you really pay attention to what
we do as posters in the seriousness with
which we approach our task is survey
scientists hopefully you will come away
convinced that in fact polling can work
now before questions us you want to know
who's going to win the election right we
don't know we don't know we can't say I
did a lot of work I've been get a lot of
heat on the email today for we did a lot
of work looking back at the Labor Day to
Election Day connection one you know we
do have some historical context right I
mean lots can change but we do have
polls on Labor Day all the way back to
Franklin Roosevelt and we have Election
Day popular vote results so we can look
at the relationships between how much
change is there well there is change you
know for galip's Labor Day poll the
median is about 6% in the gap change so
of all the elections that we've looked
at generally about half of them the gap
has moved more than 6.7 or more points
the extreme was back in a 20-point
movement for Franklin Roosevelt
there have been 14-point movements
explain some more examples in a moment
where our Labor Day poll by the time the
debates were held and advertising went
on
the electorate had moved significantly
over that two-month period on the other
hand in about half the elections it's
been less than six points in other words
what you saw on Labor Day despite all
the campaigning was very much
representative of how the final election
ended up so you look at all the data you
can say it is quite possible the data
that the election is going to move
between now and Election Day but on the
other hand there's certainly a
possibility that it won't a bush is
ahead we're in a democratic so-called
blue state in New Jersey although the
latest Eagleton poll showed what Kerry
had by only four points of George W Bush
so in fact we were talking about it
today there's some discussion that maybe
we ought to be pulling in New Jersey
because is it possible it could tip the
bush this year my response is if New
Jersey tips the bush we might as well
stop pulling because it's going to be
like an exxon ian sweep in 1972 for bush
if that's happening but nevertheless
after the convention it looks much
better for bush at the short term but
where we are today bush is ahead in our
latest poll among likely voters seven
points 52 percent for george w bush
forty five percent for john kerry and
one percent for Ralph Nader and that's
of last this last Sunday a CBS News poll
this morning seven point gap ABC
Washington Post poll released just hours
ago before I came over here nine points
52 percent and then forty three percent
for John Kerry you look at all the polls
that have come out recently and they're
all showing after the GOP convention of
some gain for George Bush the key
question is what I just mentioned does
that mean that Bush is a shoo-in for the
election and that's where I'm giving you
the statistics everything else being
equal he who is ahead on Labor Day is
more likely to win than he who is not
similar to a football game the team that
is ahead at halftime is a higher
probability of winning than the team
that is behind it halftime but certainly
you all know of games where there was a
strong come-from-behind a good news for
the Kerry campaign is to look back at
1980 1948 1976 even 1968 these were
elections where the leader at labor days
lead collapsed going into election day
and it became close if it didn't flip
carries best example probably would be
1980 the Gallup poll showed Carter ahead
by four points on Labor Day right after
the conventions Labor Day 1980 Carter
you may remember it's in all the papers
was President 1980 Reagan was a
challenger Carter four points ahead is
the incumbent
there were debates there was the Ryan
hostages the dust settled Reagan won by
10 points popular vote so a 14-point
change in the gap occurred between Labor
Day and Election Day back in 1980 you
flip back to 48 I told you a moment ago
and even larger flip between Dewey being
ahead in our poll and Truman winning you
look in 1968 Nixon at a comfortable
double-digit lead over Hubert Humphrey
at our Labor Day poll massive
campaigning went on in 68 demonstrations
Humphrey closed the gap not quite enough
Nixon won in the popular vote he won by
less than 1% and then you even go to
1976 Gerald Ford was behind the
incumbent of insurgent to Gore governor
of Georgia Jimmy Carter you know by nine
points something on those lines Carter
still won but the race had collapsed
down to only two points popular gold by
the time it was over to there again is a
movement of at least seven points in the
gap so clearly we have examples where
candidates who are behind on Labor Day
end up winning the election so it really
is an answer to the question we have
other examples like the 1960 election
where it was close on Labor Day it ended
up being close we have examples like
1984 with Reagan where he expanded his
lead which would be the hope for the
Bush supporters if there are any in this
crowd the Reagan / Mondale actually got
a bigger lead as the campaign went on or
Bill Clinton in 96 although dole picked
up some by the time the popular vote was
over that Clinton was ahead the whole
time you know there's never any serious
threat from Bob Dole back in 1996 so
anything the bottom line here is I
promise you I will tell you who's going
to win the election but I'm reneging on
that promise at this point right I do
believe you would have to assign a
slightly higher probability of a Bush
victory at this point in a carry victory
simply based on the fact that we have
less than two months to go and he's
ahead at this point but we have enough
historical examples of significant
change between Labor Day and Election
Day to hold out hope for Kerry
supporters that in fact there could be
some significant changes between now and
then we have most importantly if if they
agree to it
Bush agrees to it the series of debates
of course that are scheduled to three
presidential debates one vice
presidential debate is scheduled which
in the past have had some significant
impact on the race all right with that I
believe we can answer yeah that's it I
don't want questions yeah you all are
stupid I don't believe in the people
bye-bye no no
now we have to we've been asked to make
sure that as you ask the question you
allow the deceased man Mike to be put in
front of you here so yes sir all right
we owe you gotta--you you violated the
first rule of the presentation you come
up with the margin of error the plus or
minus two percent one percent so forth
yeah good question and it's in the book
next yeah
how's that for selling books right
actually I do discuss it in the book it
actually it is fairly complex but the
margin of error that you hear so much
about is simply what I was saying it's a
mathematical representation of what
statisticians tell us happen when you
take a sample and you then look at what
the population value is from which the
sample comes and we know that if you
take a sample it's not going to the mean
or the proportion whatever your
statistic is in the sample it's not
going to precisely represent the
population parameters they'll be a
little error if you have a thousand
marbles 500 white 500 black you shake it
up and you draw out a hundred of the
marbles you're going to be close to
50/50 when you shake it up well but it
won't be precise so the margin of error
simply takes into the count
mathematically the fact that any sample
we have is an estimate so I told you our
poll said that Kerry was ahead by 52
excuse me would that be nice for the
Kerry supporters in the audience Bush is
ahead at 52 Kerry at 45 well what that
simply we have a margin of error three
per point three percentage points now on
our point estimates percentage estimate
what that's really telling us is that
hypothetically we could have taken
another sample on the same three days
and we could have had Bush at 51 or 50
or 53 or 54 so we're really saying that
there's a range 52 is our best point
estimate at this point but since it is
just a sample you have to realize that
there is a a sloping bell shape of other
possibilities that are possible there so
you don't take the 52 to the bank but
you say generally speaking 95 times out
of 100 that's a fairly accurate
representation for those young people
those who have kids in the audience the
best way to look at that is what ETS
sends out with SATs remember if you've
got an SAT report recently or your kids
had they say you made for most kids here
what you know 780 on both sides of the
SAT let's say 500 but it will say your
response is within the range of whatever
it says you know if you made 500 on the
burbot I'll say 482 to 520 it'll give
you a range because ETS is telling us
too
even a margin of error when you take a
test that the same kid who takes the
test tomorrow is going to score in
roughly the same range but probably not
precisely where he or she scored it and
it's basically the same principle yeah
you had the question before so I wanted
to get back to I'll wait for the
microphone first of all I have an
observation about the election results
the poll results right now I feel that
since that all the hysteria in New York
and the all the dirt that was that these
people that hate Kerry dug up on him is
going to backfire so I don't believe the
polls
I think it's you know as close as it can
possibly be I don't believe in the
second of all you said that Lyndon
Johnson was highly intelligent
according time a Texan according to
according to all records of his
abilities and his and his wet school
records he was not very very very
proficient in anything he was very low
in his rate in his school work he
Kennedy was very intelligent Clinton was
very intelligent Nixon was also quite
intelligent but I don't think he might
have been very shrewd and he was very
calmly good pulling me into the
laterally you know what is the
definition of intelligence I'm just
plowing through I think the third volume
in Robert Caro's biography of Lyndon
Johnson and I have come away with a lot
of respect for Lyndon Johnson something
maybe you're right shrewdness insights
and all of it he was a very very smart
man in many ways even though he scored
perhaps low at Southwest Texas State
Teachers College in San Marcos in
relationship to your first point
absolutely that's the point I was making
things change we've got two months now
of extraordinarily intensive campaigning
both campaigns are going to be spending
hundreds of millions of dollars we're
going to have debates we're gonna have
news cover we're gonna have real world
events a terrorism in Iraq and economy
things that can happen
so it would be startling if nothing
changed you know if the boat we see
today in our polls is what we find on
Election Day that would be shocking
because we've got two months of
intensive efforts to change people's
minds and at least some people probably
will change their minds yes ma'am wait
for the mic okay when you do your sample
how much how carefully do you select
regionally speaking from different parts
of the country one of the criticisms
many years ago about the Gallup poll was
that they polled mainly from the Midwest
and tended to do less so from the
coastal areas
how do you control for that type of
sampling a good question I don't believe
that that was valid in terms of the
Gallup poll if nothing else dr. Gallup
was extraordinarily focused on quotas
and making sure that the sample was
representative we basically to make a
long story short have every phone number
every residential phone number in
America and we sample proportionately
from it you know 10% plus of the u.s.
population lives in California therefore
10% of all residential phone numbers
listed and unlisted are in California
so in our broad sample of all
residential phone numbers sample
proportionately roughly 10% will come
from California so it's very
proportional now to check that we said
regional quotas on our sampling to make
sure we're doing it right when were
through with our sample we then double
check it back against census parameters
on region so by the time we're through
and announce of poll we're almost
absolutely sure that it is
geographically representative we do hear
that a lot if Republicans don't like our
sampling say all you do is interview in
Hollywood in Manhattan we here and if
Democrats don't like our sample we say
oh yeah there you go again interviewing
in Utah Alabama and Texas those the only
states you go to it's a common criticism
but it's not true we were very sensitive
to geography yes what assault weapon ban
is due to expire I wondered if there's
any trend in what the Americans believe
do they seem to be more willing to
accept that expiration yes you know we
haven't polled on that recently but but
historically Americans although very
very sensitive to not taking away the
right to have a gun this is important on
many social issues Americans are very
sensitive to not take away the right to
do something but they are very much in
favor of restrictions and Americans
historically have been very much in
favor of restrictions on assault weapons
and other kinds of guns along those
lines so I think it's fair to say that
our data would show that Americans given
a choice like the idea of a ban on
assault weapons
I heard today I believe the Senate
Majority Leader Princeton graduates
saying somehow the people didn't want
the banned renewed but I find that not
jiving with at least what I believe is
our data although we don't have maybe he
has some new poll he just completed over
the weekend that shows him that but
that's an instance where I believe the
public is quite willing to live with
controls on guns as long as you don't
take away the right to own a gun by the
way the very sensitive issue politically
is abortion and we find exactly the same
thing Americans very willing to have
restrictions on a board
in fact Americans generally want
restrictions but they are not willing to
have Roe versus Wade done away with they
want a woman to have the right they
don't want to take away the right at the
same time that they want to restrictions
yes we thought about that today
the responsibility is responsibility
it's an excellent time for us as
pollsters to be out there if not asking
the question to interject it make sure
we publish it get it on our website as
soon as possible exactly in line with
what I'm saying in the book we want the
government to know what the public think
about assault weapons an excellent point
we were talking about that today yes sir
what if a leader knew exactly how the
majority of the American public felt on
every issue and responded exactly to
that in other words supported exactly
what the American public felt do you
think he'd be doing the right job do you
think that that would be the right thing
in general yes in fact I even have I
know many people don't I even have a
chapter at the end of the book called
about yeah his question was if a leader
literally did nothing but ascertain what
the majority the public felt and then
followed those wishes would he be doing
a good job
Arda Swardson ager said at the
republican convention the other night
great leaders don't pay attention to
polls which by the way I say means great
leaders don't pay attention to the
public which I disagree with but I have
it even in the in the end of my book I
have a hypothetical situation what I
call the pollster candidate a man or
woman maybe people tell me I should do
it maybe I will sin to run for office
and say please vote for me I have no
convictions no issues and no positions
all I pledge to you the people all I
pledge to you the people is that I will
do my best to consistently and
constantly maintain a an extraordinary
touch of what you the collective views
of the people want me to do in these
situations and that's what I will follow
and if a lobbyist comes to me says let
me take you to dinner or contribute to
your campaign to get you to vote in this
way that I say no don't go to me go to
the people because I'll follow through
the people now in reality we need
leaders to make decision you cannot ask
the people whether to fund the new for
junior class submarine or stop to see
you know you can't do these things we
need leaders we have many esoteric
elements of American International
Society where we need leaders to make
informed
decisions but in general I would say we
need leaders who move more in the
direction of paying more attention to
the collective wisdom of the people and
less attention to their own views or the
views of lobbyists special interests and
party bosses which is where they get a
lot of their instincts from at this
point leaders shouldn't pay attention to
the people
I think he should whenever he could he
could he is she but I also think that
there are times when he might be opposed
he is she in principle and with some
issues and there are times when he
really knows that the majority opinion
is wrong and that collects enough to
tough juncture that I talked about in
the book you know the Abraham Lincoln
pushing for the war when the public may
not have we didn't have polling but we
don't know what the public thought about
that
Franklin Roosevelt by the way paid
attention to polls that's why he held
back from getting in World War two
because the public was quite
isolationist yeah there is a this is the
Nexus of the argument where you say
leaders sometimes know more than the
public well wiser than the public should
do what they want well you know I
believe at the very least that it's out
of kilter where there's too much of that
type of thinking as Phil Gramm said when
he was asked how he's going to vote on
impeachment of Bill Clinton the great
people of Texas didn't send me to
Washington to pay attention to polls and
I say yes they did senator Gramm they
said you watch me to pay attention to
what they want at least he should have
spent a lot more time paying attention
to the public that's the issue that I
come down very strongly on the face of
let's spend less let's have less
reverence for and respect for the
assumed wisdom of those we elect to
represent us in more reverence and
respect for the collective views of
those of us in this room and the people
and I think in the long run our society
will move in a much much better
direction I honestly do yes right here
you do an election poll several days
before the election have you ever looked
to see does the result of that sometime
alters some voters to change in other
words they want to be with a majority
and change their their votes good
question if you didn't hear it he was
saying do poll results particularly an
election actually turn around and affect
the views of other people in the society
George Gallup call that the bandwagon
effect you know everybody's voting for
Exxon going to - although as he said
mathematically it obviously doesn't
happen a lot because every election to
be a hundred to nothing
think about it for a moment logic
poll shows us 50 poll shows it 6240 in
favor of candidate X well that 40 if
that worked would look at the polls and
say oh I want to be with the majority so
I'm going to vote for the majority so
the next day it would be 70/30 then the
thirty would look at the polls and say
oh I want to be with the majority and it
would soon be 8020 in fact that doesn't
happen and those who are behind in the
polls often can surge it at the very it
s Howard Dean Wright where he was doing
so well in the polls was there a great
rush of Democrats to support Dean in the
latter / no you know Kerry came from
nowhere in one so there's no strong
evidence that there is a classic
bandwagon effect but more importantly I
don't care if there is I think that if
an boater wants to take into account the
the width of feelings the attitudes the
opinions of his or her fellow citizens
is represented in polls that's great
I was interviewed on Sylvania TV today
believe it or not and they say we in
Slovenia have a week's band before an
election where you cannot report public
opinion eh that's impossible today
because of the internet it's going to
get out there anyhow but drugs will have
it there is a poll but B that's
ridiculous in my opinion yeah I have a
great faith in the public in a John Q or
Jane Q public wants to change his or her
vote because she wants to either before
against the majority in the polls more
power to them I believe it was
tremendous in California that our poll
and others showed as we led to the
recall election that Arnold
Schwarzenegger was ahead in the polls
and was likely to be the one elected to
replace recall governor Gray Davis the
process of democracy was better served
in California because of that
pre-election point why because the
citizens of California knew ahead of
time that there was a real possibility
that actor Arnold Schwarzenegger was
going to be elected governor this came
in Slovenia would have been a shock a
surprise when they woke up on Election
Day no the good citizens of California
knew this ahead of time
polling told them that and yet they
continue to vote for him I think that's
a great plus okay
anyhow I'm in favor last question yeah
right here ma'am wait after you very
carefully select your sample by all your
statistical methods how do you account
for the people who hang up I never see
pro/con who is a pro/con don't know
where do those people come in excellent
point it's that you're asking about
respond
trait but the real question is response
bias when we collect an initial we pull
an initial sample think about it
logically the phone numbers 2,000
hypothetically let's say we ended up
only completing interviews with a
thousand some of the people we call are
never home we call repeatedly repeated
calls they don't some are busy at all
time some of them are businesses
although we weed those out and some of
them are flat-out non-cooperation to
refusals and unfortunately with
telemarketing that's more common now
than it has been in the past so we are
often asked is doesn't this somehow make
the process not effective it doesn't
what we're really looking for is not the
fact that our response rate is low that
is fewer people we we complete
interviews with fewer people than in the
initial sample but does that introduce
bias that would be the issue the issue
would be if those who hung up on us that
were never home
systematically let's say in an election
environment we're more likely to vote
Democrat or Republican all of the
evidence to date at any rate suggests
that that is not a significant problem
that despite the fact that our response
rates have been declining due to a
variety of reasons including technology
like call waiting and caller ID and
things on and cell phone only households
and also telemarketing poisoning the
well as it were making people less
receptive to a legitimate Gallup caller
when the phone does ring at night
despite all of that we have found that
the samples we get although with the
lower response rates that we might have
gotten twenty years ago are still very
accurate there's no evidence to date
that a systematic bias has been
introduced into process but the bottom
line here is and this is the last point
scientifically we are concerned about
that we have been for years as an
industry there are papers there are
scientists studying their whole
conferences convened to study nothing
but issues of response bias so we are I
can I I would I would say this we were
on top of the issue and monitoring the
extremely carefully if it does appear
that bias has been introduced we're
looking for other methods to pull but to
date that we are confident put the poll
out otherwise we believe that even with
the declining response rate our sample
is a legitimate representation of the
population from which it is drawn all
right thank you very much
Frank Newport is editor in chief of the
Gallup poll for more information on
polling matters visit the publishers
website at TW bookmark dot-com
[Music]